[Música]
[Aplausos]
bien
ustedes repensando reflexionando sobre
nuestra sociedad y sobre cómo hacer de
esto un lugar mejor más justo sin
violencia y más consciente
[Aplausos]
strato de nuestro segundo original que
se llama eso
en este montaje lo que queremos es que
los espectadores a través del humor y la
crítica social y la sátira puedan
cuestionarse y reflexionar sobre sus
propias prácticas sobre sus realidades y
sobre las cosas que pasan en el lugar
donde vivimos los invitamos y los
invitamos a escuchar con atención y
esperamos que el hecho
[Aplausos]
[Música]
sí
el mundo
[Aplausos]
ah
[Música]
quiera
[Aplausos]
agua segura
'operación retorno'
convivencia bien prohibición del
edificio
comando cumpla lo que es el chileno
[Música]
ah
puede ser
[Música]
[Aplausos]
cómo
a
[Aplausos]
[Música]
luego viendo vivimos empresarios de
entre medio
[Aplausos]
con la mamita entre medio
pasados estuve cansado por la mañana
cansado de nuevo en la tarde y así todas
las semanas que piñera en vacaciones su
merecido descanso te sale mucho bajaron
los para atrás que para mal
y el gobierno mínimo aquí la iglesia
mete mano para estar bien la cuestión es
solamente perversa él es un hombre de
dios
los niños son tentadores y no el
destierro el señor amigo
hablamos muy despacito también chiquito
y con permisito que pena por vidrios
hito que somos tan weon sido disculpe en
este momento no queremos incomodar está
dicho en chiquitito perdone por
favorcito
[Música]
y el gobierno vieron sol
se dedica a la región y el norte viví el
agente vinimos
[Música]
esta tarde
tampoco tener un hijo mucho menos
separarse comiéndose muros vídeos pero
atrás de viejo no te pescas del chileno
en lo que hoy es el chileno en lo peor
el chileno es lo peor
dice chileno ya no es tan malo no porque
va para el mundial de fútbol
igual nos fuimos al mundial de junio
amor si vamos ahí no si no fuimos no ve
que está todo el mundo llorando
ay mi amor es que yo te estoy hablando
de la selección de fútbol de mujeres que
va a el mundial
[Música]
y eso porque no sale en la tele porque
no ve es por mi amor si todo lo que
están en la tele de basura o en mentira
métetelo viene en la tableta mira entre
comedias turcas noticieros matinales por
policías hoy además que ahora yo no te
pido me da tanta pena acordarme de su
muerte mi abuelo bueno igual esperan
verdad que estábamos nuevo igual y de
nuevo te está yendo con la rama que te
estaba hablando yo hablé porque ya no
era tan malo ser chileno no es malo mi
amor es de perro como dicen los lolos
pero hay una cosa mucho peor que ser
chileno excusa bien
escuchen miren atentos una historia
contará la hamburguesa mike anuda de
otro lado va a escuchar hay una cosa
terrible si llegas a ser mujer mala
suerte ser chilena no lo quiere en mí
creer despierta para el trabajo a todos
sirve el café primero dejar los niños al
colegio otra vez y secar el
reconfortante respeto en el viajar
nunca nadie se cuartea mucho menos la
cansadas de su pega después trabajo en
la casa que tiene para hacer de empleada
saneadas y al fin llega en
vacaciones su merecido descanso igual te
que hay cuidando cabros chicos pero
llegó bien vivimos en la iglesia metida
en todos
de los condones a todo dicen que no se
nota que ya le falta ejercicio me dio
para menos en sueldos pagamos más le
ponemos más que hombre jubilado
el nieto para que también te explota
hasta tu familia no te dejan ni vejez
dime de qué nos sirve
y dime de qué nos sirven
discursos sobre igualdad
si la realidad se cambia con acciones de
verdad
no pedimos nada a cambio
sino un sincero respeto que hay mucha
mujer que sabe más que hombre
luego viene son dueños de nuestro cuerpo
por favor del archivo de misterio vivan
ya y vieja para sí no
[Música]
[Aplausos]
ya que es tarde
pero tarde para que más vale tarde que
nunca huele y nuestra cuerda que nos
dijeron aquí que la costa entre del
tiempo
porque hacen eso si todavía queda tiempo
y todavía queda tiempo y más y más yo
tengo que hablar me hacen me va a ver un
mes ya ya bueno yo tengo que seguir
hablándole a hablar de sobre nosotras la
murga que nosotros realizamos es un
género músico teatral que proviene de
uruguay allá las murgas son
principalmente de hombres este fue uno
de los motivos que hace ya casi siete o
más de siete años llevó a la
conformación de esta agrupación murgas
sanz by canuta que hoy se define como
una agrupación feminista autogestionada
y que a través de la voz y la música
busca denunciar y reflexionar sobre
temáticas que nos afectan como
ciudadanas y como ciudadanos de esta
sociedad y de este mundo que habitamos
para nosotras la autogestión además de
generar nuestros propios recursos
económicos ha significado el trabajo
colectivo para la realización y gestión
de nuestros montajes como gran logro de
la autogestión queremos destacar la
grabación de nuestro primer disco de
calidad profesional que se llama como
nuestro show hecho en chile para
terminar
queremos dejarles con mucho cariño
nuestra retirada un aplauso para la
murga
[Aplausos]
[Música]
nuevas
te llevo a ti
porque tú eres mi luz
sé que nada impedirá
de que nada impedirá
sé que nada impedirá a recordarte
[Música]
por sentir
d
vuelvo por sentir el pulso de mi sueño
[Música]
encendiendo certidumbres y desvelo
vuelvo por la ilusión de regresar
mi cantar
[Música]
traigo de lejos unas enteros
que va
mi ser
ya
[Música]
vengo a dar mi huella
vengo a las rocas de tu orilla
y nostalgia
hombre
me condena en cenizas
sus aguas sortea la distancia que
alejado
de tu luna
y ahora mi comida
no sobran
la zona
acciones en el alma
somos parte de esta tierra spears
encadenadas tantos años de exiliadas su
materia de volver
es la partera que sembró nacer dando a
luz en las calles las leyendas del ayer
quisiera vestirlo y retazos de mañana
entregada plenamente en tu alborada de
un nuevo esplendor
y a cargo rancho camino
el sucesor es local
hoy recibimos su senda abrazar quiere
andar reencontrarnos
dt en el tiempo en tus manos
esta noche perpetua que todos cantos los
cantos por ti hoy es en chile llegó a su
fin
explota la bolsa explota la voz al
cantar
la tristeza se retira
el amor la que te da
cantar
la vida un eterno rival
una tristeza escondida
cereté
no me digas algas jamás cuando el
destino nos quiera separar
mi alma sin rumbo no descansará hasta
volverte a encontrar
zamba canuta se va se va te dejo el beso
te anuncia el final
todos las vivas conmigo quedarán sé que
me esperara
no me faltes jamás prometo volver mi
canción traeré para verte otra vez
la despedida voy a traicionar al vivir
nuestro eterno carnaval
by canutas además de lo que hago
nos la dio
[Música]
sé que me esperara no me faltes jamás
prometo volver mi canción traeré para
verte otra vez
la despedida voy a traicionar al vivir
[Aplausos]
carnaval